i'm actually not a good gift giver uh
no i will tell my husband i'm like don't
get me anything because then that means
i have to give him something
um and i'll be doing that i got the kids
covered
you know but any any other thing i'm
like can we just draw for presents
like i don't need anything and but
usually i'm on the road this year i feel
like my christmas
was was uh i was i was a little more on
point and had my decorations up earlier
and had my christmas shopping done
earlier
because i actually had time to do it so
usually i get home like a week before
christmas and i'm scrambling you know
yeah but now you're like you're way
ready this year i actually got mike a
present
and he got me cows which is what i
wanted so
i'm sorry he got you what i wanted cows
for christmas
i love cows are my favorite animal i
love them they make me happy
i don't want them for any purpose just
to love them
are we talking like ornaments and like
things on the
no we're talking like real cows new cows
we have two little calves
in uh in our little front pasture area
well carrie may not believe she's the
best gift giver this year she delivered
the ultimate present to her fans her
first ever christmas album
and an hbo max special my gift a
christmas special from carrie underwood
[Music]
if we called your husband and asked him
if you were on the naughtiness list or
the nice list what would you say
um might depend on what day you ask him
um i i think i'm pretty good we've made
it through
a difficult year with a whole lot of
together time
so i feel like that's good let the world
stay still
the church bells ring
i think we've spent all of us time with
our partners that
we haven't spent before how's that been
for you
about three o'clock is when it starts
getting hard
because in the morning you know you've
got your morning routine
um you breakfast and you're getting
ready for the day and then you've got
lunch
and then the baby goes to sleep for a
little bit and then at about
three o'clock is when it's like what do
we do when he retired it was a big
transition and i'm like you're home all
the time yay
um but i was still super busy and then
this year we were all home
a lot but you know we we've done really
well and i feel like we've managed to do
things to keep ourselves busy